ordering fractions is the heading which
you have plenty of time to make by now
yesterday we just looked at the idea of
what a fraction was we also pulled out
the different kinds of fractions
do you remember okay proper fractions
right so I think the example I gave you
was uh-huh importantly the numerator is
I smaller than the denominator
yes okay so what happens what did we
call it when the numerator is larger if
I had say 3 over 2
good so this is proper improper what was
the last one yep
mix numerals ok how he can give me an
example 1 I guess let's try this again
mix new rules let's try an easier one
how great that song that's 3 over 2
that's the improper fraction and this is
the equivalent mix numeral ok great so
proper fractions improper fractions big
supers great ok now we know what they
are we know how to write them we know
how to interpret them right but now just
think about how do we order them ok now
sorry I'm just rewriting can I use the
value I for the first time maybe we
looked at ordering integers last term
didn't win okay and all you need to
think about was you know whole numbers
they're really easy to order ok when you
add in a negative sign you've got sign
that changes the direction of the number
you just have to remember that even
though this value you might be larger
what effect is the negative 1/2 how I
rearrange this so that the order is
correct where were there negative 4 guys
yeah
effect yeah she go it's the smallest
step a lot right even though the number
is the largest you need to remember that
sign means it's going in the opposite
direction
you drew number lines you learned how to
do this okay that's all fine okay a
whole numbers integers quite easy to
order think about this right if you
wanted one five or two pies or three
pies which would be the best offer right
because I like pies you're like well
more players equals more better right so
you'd pick three players and that's
simple when you throw fractions in the
mix it becomes a little less clear for
instance if I said well you can't have
the whole pie forget it I want some of
the playa - I'll give you a choice
suppose you can have you can have you
can have you can have two fifths supply
or you can have three sevenths sevenths
of the pie okay oh maybe I'll give you
five seventeen of the pie okay I could
get on not now we can work out which one
is a better deal right which one will
give you more pie and don't we all one
more pie okay but it is certainly not as
obvious as with the whole numbers why
not
why isn't it so clear what's the
difference
okay good now it's not being whole
numbers the particular thing that makes
it harder to put beeping order is these
guys these are what make them fractions
right what did we call them again the
denominators now the denominators are
different
what are we just establish different
denominators make a different sized
fraction okay so how can we order this
how can we work out which one of these
is the best option for pipe or maybe if
you dislike the pipe is which one is the
smallest okay
testing one don't tell you how much
there is